from the early days of the corona virus
pandemic doctors on the front line have
relaid promising news about the anti
malaria drug hydroxychloroquine the
president wanted to cheer up a
frightened nation cited that drug at one
point as potential therapy because the
president was hopeful the press was the
opposite of that
basically the opposed finding a cure for
the corona virus because they feared it
might give the president some political
advantage this was everywhere here are a
few examples the USA Today wrote this
quote doctor Donald Trump peddle snake
oil and false hope
Cina and needless to say said the same
quote Trump pedals unsubstantiated hope
in dark times the Washington posed to
loathsome publication barely even a
newspaper now a few days later declared
this quote Trump is giving people false
hope of coronavirus cures it's all snake
oil cliches being a specialty over at
the Washington Post none of these people
had any clue any freaking clue what they
were talking about in fact they're the
ones who are peddling unsubstantiated
snake oil hydroxychloroquine is still
being researched but this will tell you
a lot doctors who were actually treating
people who are sick with the corona
virus seemed to believe in it many of
them do here's how we know that a global
survey of 6,200 medical professionals
currently fighting the corona virus
pandemic found that hydroxychloroquine
was the most frequently cited drug they
would turn to to treat patients it had
the plurality 37 percent it was number
one out of fifteen options the biggest
believers in hydroxychloroquine we're
not people who watch fox news or even
governed by donald trump they were
doctors in Spain in Italy two countries
where the epidemic has been the worst
just to let you know unequivocally and
for all time that the media lied about a
potential therapy to defeat this disease
and save your life because their
political partisans that tells you
everything you need to know Fox medical
interpreter dr. mark Segal joins us
tonight doctor thanks so much for coming
on without dragging you into all the
political nonsense
that's not your world not where you live
not where you want to live
tell us what doctors are saying about
I took her first of all
hydroxychloroquine has been looked at in
the test tube in China and found to be
very very effective against this
coronavirus specifically a part of the
cell where the virus enters that was a
very strong study then China also had
some follow-up studies where they looked
at the effects in people and it looked
very effective in people in France we've
talked about a study in France which was
pretty small but showed that it was
effective now as you said doctors have
been using it all over the United States
many are saying that it's working
we've seen it in New York State giving
it to hundreds of people right now in
hospitals with a lot of promising signs
and finally the University of
Pennsylvania has just begun a major
double blinded randomized prospective
clinical trial and you know when they do
that when they spend that kind of money
when they believe a treatment may work
so I can't prove to you that it works at
this point but it's extremely promising
and there's a lot of evidence that it
does work that's so interesting it's it
do you think and this is politically
tinged but I cannot resist the terrible
publicity this drug has received just
relentlessly over the past three weeks
this is a crackpot cure this is snake
oil do you think that has made
physicians hesitant to try to try it as
a therapy no I think physicians go with
what works I think physicians are facing
a situation where they don't know what
to offer patients where patients are
getting worse and the idea that there's
a drug out there that's very well
tolerated for malaria prophylaxis and
for right for rheumatoid arthritis and
lupus that you could use it for
something like this makes doctors want
to try it right that's right good I mean
I think a lot of us have I know I've
taken it on trips to broad to malaria
zone sub-saharan Africa or whatever it's
a common drug so here's another question
I just want to ask there's a message you
said you'd like to deliver to nurses and
doctors tonight fighting the corona
virus what is it
Tucker Caius Kelly was a nurse who died
last week tragically may not have had
enough personal protective equipment in
New York
John Murray is a
ninety-two year-olds physician who
helped of discover the kind of lung
problem that's actually killing people
from coronavirus and he died of
coronavirus we've been seeing a lot of
medical professionals on the front lines
emergency technicians nurses doctors
over 60 doctors in Italy have died
trying to treat the kovat 19 coronavirus
I have a medical student who I trained
and he is now graduating three months
early at NYU Langone Medical Center to
go on the frontlines to fight kovat 19
he's reinvesting his soul in why he went
into medicine in the first place he has
fear he has worried about his family's
name is gay by the way but he is
investing himself a lot of doctors
around New York right now are changing
their professions they're going from
being an orthopedist or being retired or
and having been on the front lines now
to go to fight the virus that's the war
against the virus healthcare workers
nurses doctors ENT East that we're on
the front lines paramedics and we should
congratulate them for their efforts I
couldn't agree more that's the rest of
us are cowering in fear and we should be
afraid and these people are jumping
face-first into a situation that could
kill them and you know I really admire
that I think we should all admire that
thank you dr. Siegel for saying that
Thank You Tucker